Stephen is in Pasadena California hi
Stephen how are you hey Dave I'm doing
good so I have a question if you can
explain because my brother I've been
talking to him about your program and he
says yeah that's all fine and stuff but
I don't see the positive in being having
a zero credit because then how am I
going to buy a house how am I going to
be able to do all these things without
having a credit score and I completely
and 100% all in on your program and
everything but I want to talk him into
it because I know they're having some
struggles with things but at the same
time I don't know how to explain that
let's start with the idea that he is
arguing with financial advice and he's
broke that's pretty soon but let's just
start there I mean this guy he really
you know he hired if you hire a personal
trainer and they tell you what to do you
ought to do it so let's start with the
idea that credit score hasn't been a
blessing for this guy he's broke he's
having financial problems so his plan
really sucks we need to start with that
idea now then we can back up and say
okay what is the technical aspects of
this buy a house and all these other
things you said he said well all these
other things are your problem you pay
cash for everything but a house and I'd
rather you pay cash for a house but zero
chance ever that you need to have any
credit card debt any student loan debt
or any card debt or any debt other than
a house if you want to be a millionaire
all these millionaires we've studied all
these not broke people like your brother
but all these people who have money that
we have studied for 30 years have
avoided debt as their primary way to
become wealthy because that allowed them
then without any payments to invest so
you save up and pay cash for your trips
your Christmas your college you save up
and pay cash for your cars your boats
your toys you save up and pay cash like
grandma said if you ain't got the money
don't buy and the money means you need
to have all the money to buy the item
and it doesn't chase you home now how to
deal with the house
without a credit score then you can
actually get a mortgage you would have
to do what's called manual underwriting
and not a lot of mortgage companies know
how to do that Churchill mortgage is one
that does know how to do it and there
are a few others but a lot of them are
just so stupid the only thing they know
how to the only loans they know how to
make are FICO loans and they look at the
FICO number and they make the loan it's
stated income loans and they're the type
of loans that are disastrous but that's
the way the industry is set up so but
you can get a manually underwritten loan
and that means that they can't just look
at the number because there's not a
number they actually have to look at the
person and verify that you have a job
and verify that you have a downpayment
and verify that you can make the
payments based on your income ratio to
your payments and they actually do
underwriting and like we used to do when
we first started there when I first
start in the real estate business 35
years ago we actually the mortgage
companies did real underwriting back
then they didn't just look at one number
and make the loan and that number being
the FICO score so the answer is yes you
can get a house no you can't get a lot
of other stuff but you shouldn't anyway
unless you pay for it and if you're
gonna stay in debt you are not following
the shortest track to becoming a
millionaire so that's the answer to his
equation the other the other thing you
got to remember is this I find myself in
the early days of this show and like you
are Steven arguing with people it's not
worth it
just go live your life you can't talk
stupid out of some people even if
they're in your family they're just
gonna be stupid so you go live your life
you're not gonna argue him into anything
he's broke and has strong opinions about
money how interestingly stupid is that
so he's arrogant and it's gonna he's
gonna have problems until he decides
he's gonna listen to someone who knows
more than he knows which includes you by
the way you know more than he knows so
sorry but that's just I've had these
conversations with people like this for
years and I just quit having them it's a
waste of good energy so I'm not going I
can't talk you into being smart
you gotta decide you're gonna get smart
and then I can help you get there but I
can't just Club you over the head and
he's not he is one to argue he's not
really one to learn and so I don't think
you can argue him into it you're
probably gonna be really frustrated
trying so I probably wouldn't try and we
probably won't have any more arguments
with you but you do whatever you want
that gives you the tools to do it either
way this is the Dave Ramsey show